كشف تقرير لصحيفه جورنال تصاعد العمليات
العسكريه ضد داعش في سوريا تحديدا في
الجزء الشمالي منها تقرير اضعف ان القوات
الامريكيه نفذت خلال شهر ديسمبر ما لا يقل
عن عشره عمليات وغارات في سوريا ضد مواقع
للتنظيم وتنقل الصحيفه عن متحدث باسم
القوات الامريكيه ان العمليات المذكوره
ادت الى اعتقاله سته من عناصر داعش
مسؤولون عسكريون اضعفوا ان المداهمات تتم
عاده في الليل باستخدام مروحيات لقوات
العمليات الخاصه الجيش الامريكي كشف ايضا
ان تلك المداهمات الذات الى مقتلي مسؤول
اقليمي كبير في تنظيم داعش ودعاء الزبيدي
كما اكد مسؤولون عسكريون تنفيذ ثمانيه
غارات اخرى من بينها سبعا في وقت سابق من
هذا الشهر وواحده اخرى في اوائل اكتوبر
ادت الى مقتل او اعتقال عناصر اخرين من
داعش اللافت في هذا التقرير ان احدى
العمليات البريه ضد داعش في سوريا استمرت
ثلاث ساعات باعت ذلك في وقتنا ارتفع في
عدد لا هجوم داعش على مقر امني للقوات
الكرديه في الرقه الى ثمانيه مقاتله
[موسيقى]